Speaker 1: You know, I have not spoken much
recently on the podcast and the broadcast because
about the Kyle Rittenhouse trial, because we've
been covering essentially the full trial every day
on Facebook and YouTube, not on Twitch, because
we're banned from Twitch for 30 days. So I've just
been getting so much of it. I haven't commented,
but I do want to talk about it a little bit today.
Over the last 24 hours, the Kyle Rittenhouse
case in Kenosha, Wisconsin. It's the trial of
Kyle Rittenhouse, who is accused of when he was
17 last year, homicide against two individuals
that he killed, as well as miscellaneous other
charges related to guns and other things. This
is a trial where the defense has now taken over.
The defense called Kyle Rittenhouse to the stand
as a witness, and the prosecution was able
to cross-examine Kyle Rittenhouse yesterday.
This has now led to a call for a mistrial by the
defense. So let's look at one article about this,
and then we're going to look at a video because
the judge flipped out yesterday. This is getting
a lot of attention because it has become quite
wacky. The Kyle Rittenhouse case is now in
jeopardy as lawyers seek a mistrial. Trial judge
accuses prosecutor of improper line of questioning
What has taken place is that the. Defense has
asked for a mistrial on two bases. The first
is that at the beginning of his cross-examination
of Kyle Rittenhouse, the prosecutor sought to ask
Kyle Rittenhouse about not making a comprehensive
public statement about what he believes happened.
The judge felt that this was trying to use
Rittenhouse's silence against him, which would be
a violation of the Fifth Amendment. OK, that's one
basis on which the defense wants a mistrial. The
other basis on that on which the defense wants
a mistrial is that, they say. The prosecutor
questioned Rittenhouse about things which the
judge had already said should not be brought
up. This is a basic summary of the reasoning for
the defense's request for a mistrial. The judge
is considering that request. The defense wants a
mistrial with prejudice, meaning that that's it,
that the case can't be restarted. A new case
can't be restarted against Kyle Rittenhouse.
That would be wild if that took place. I also
want to play for you. VIDEO When this was being
discussed of the judge sort of flipping out on the
prosecutor, take a look at this in the questions.
Speaker 2: I asked the court to strongly
admonish him, and the next time it happens,
I'll be asking for a mistrial with prejudice.
He's an experienced attorney and he knows better.
Mr. Finger, first of all, your honor, this was
the subject of emotion. I'm well aware of that.
And the court left the door
open to me. Not for you.
Well, my understanding is you should have come
and asked for the air for reconsideration you
did on the one motion, and in fact, I granted your
motion for a reconsider. That was in a nutshell.
Excuse me. I had I did agree that we did not
move for reasons. We've not filed any motions
to reconsider this case. That was their motion
for reconsideration, which I denied. But I said
I denied it. All right. Indicate a
bias towards denial is what I did.
Held it open with a bias towards denial. Why would
you think that that made it OK for you without any
advance notice to bring this matter before the
jury? You are already you're. I was astonished
when you began your examination by commenting
on the defendant's post arrest silence. That's
Basic Law. It's been Basic Law in this
country for 40 years, 50 years. I have
no idea why you would do something like that.
Speaker 1: So as many have noticed, the judge
seems to only bring this level of energy against
the prosecution. There have been a whole bunch
of questions raised about this judge and listen.
If the judge is biased, there's going to be the
possibility of an appeal. In theory, although
prosecution appeals and jury verdicts are very,
very tough, I want to just kind of give my general
take on this case at this point in time because
I'm getting a lot of emails from people saying,
David, this is obviously self-defense. David, even
Twitty now says it was self-defense. I don't know
what Twitty has said. To be clear, I'm just saying
people are telling me that that's what Twitty has
said. Let me make my position on this case very,
very clear. I believe that Kyle Rittenhouse
is self-defense. From a legal perspective
is going to be valid enough, plausible enough in
the immediate situation in which he shot the two
people that he killed, that he will be found
not guilty. I believe that it is a plausible.
I believe it may be quite true that
he feared for his life in that moment,
which is what is on trial. OK, so I'm not saying
any of this. You know, he's obviously guilty,
it obviously wasn't self-defense. I think that
from a legal standpoint, self-defense is going
to be valid enough based on the fact that
not guilty will be the verdict there. I also
believe that the entire context here is a
disgusting context. He had no business going to
Kenosha and being armed that night. The totality
of the incident is nauseating and the fact that
if he's convicted, he will be considered
a martyr by the right. If he is acquitted,
he will be made a hero by the right for the fact
that he was there with a gun defending himself
when the truth is that this case is emblematic of
everything wrong with American culture around guns
masculinity. Vigilante justice, cetera, etc.. Now
you can break down each part and say, well, OK,
in general, just for being a 17 year old,
being familiar with guns is not inherently
wrong or immoral. In theory, protecting property
while holding a gun? It's not. I mean, you know,
would we feel differently as a viewer e-mailed
me if this was someone protecting a black owned
business with a gun from KKK, looters or something
like that? Most progressives would probably say
no, that it's OK, that that's being done. And
if you do this, you certainly can make the case
that there's no particular one smoking gun. But
this is a symptom of toxic underlying conditions,
gun culture, vigilante culture, et cetera. And
that is different than should he be found guilty.
That's not a crime. What I just said. So let's not
misstate each other's beliefs about this. And for
the people emailing me saying, David, you're so
wrong for saying that he should be found guilty.
It's for the jury to decide. And I believe that
the evidence for the narrow circumstances at issue
in the case self-defense is plausible
and that he will be found not guilty
on the homicides. That's my belief. Send me your
thoughts. You can find me on Twitter at Packman.